Dude. Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Bird,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon. Just
before Friday, Monday morning podcast.
And
just checking in on you.
Um, what's going on?
I am back the United States of America.
Well,
you can get a gun.
You can marry a man and where,
uh,
I dunno, you can, you
can go get a big goal.
You can do whatever the fuck
you want here man. This is mark
land of the brave.
Okay.
Well the
land of the slurpee.
Um, yes. Got back yesterday. Uh,
pretty easy flight. You know,
I thought it was going to be a,
I was going to be a rough one. Okay. Um,
got on with my wife
and my lovely daughter.
And of course my daughter
started screaming bloody
murder right in the beginning.
Cause you know, poor thing,
it's tough for him. Right?
And this fucking guy in front of us,
right? We're flying business class.
Everybody's got a little bit of the
uh, Hey, you know, we almost made it,
didn't we didn't we almost it all
20 rows away from first class.
Um,
and my daughter did some high pitched
scream and the guy just fucking put his
hand straight up in the year.
Like really?
They started and then he started
turning around looking at us.
So I fucking pop my head up like a
goddamn something to meet his eyes.
Like, dude, a really, it's a
fucking baby. He used to be a baby.
You were on a plane and you were
screaming, you fucking asshole.
People like you have problems with
babies crying, like, you know,
as much of a cunt that I am, I, I
have not had a problem with that.
It actually, you know, baby
start crying or playing,
it makes me set this before it makes
me laugh because they're expressing
literally what I'm thinking.
I'm ready to just start crying.
I don't want to fucking do this,
you know,
how far is it [inaudible]
you born in Queen,
I guess, right? They,
nobody listens to them.
They're all standing up this shoving
jackets in the overhead compartments,
you know, they're acting like
a bunch of babies. So anyways,
but later on the flight, I
ran into the guy up front, uh,
when he was poured himself a drink and I
went up, then I got to drink. I said, hey,
sorry about the baby crying.
And he's like, oh no problem.
It's a baby. But both, oh,
now you're a good guy. Now you're giving
them for the rest of the flight. He was,
he was cool. He just make it faces at
her and shit. You know, I get it. Yup.
Yup.
You're paid for business class.
You're about ready to take a 10 hour
flight and some kids screaming bloody
murder yet, you know, really
kind of ruins it. But you know,
that's what they made earplugs for.
There was like three babies
in our section and uh,
they were all putting on their own show.
But um,
after a while my daughter settled down,
but she scared the daylights
out of a lot of people. Um,
there's a lot of people that are
just fucking selfish assholes.
Like they were born adults.
You know, the looks that they,
they've, they fucking give you or the,
we even worse, they'll give you a kid.
It's just like, wow. It makes me feel
better about myself, man. I mean, I,
I know I'm an asshole,
but Jesus, you know, I,
I stopped short of mean
Muggin of fucking toddler.
Uh, I know I've probably
done that, not a toddler,
but when I see a fucking spoiled Brat in
a store and his parents have no control
over him or her and she wants something
or he wants something and they don't get
in, they start fucking crying. Oh Man. If
they make eye contact with me, I'll, I'll,
I'll shoot him a look. I admit
it, I'll do it. You know,
I love it when the parent doesn't give,
it,
doesn't give the kid the fucking
toy or the peace, whatever,
the candy bar or whatever
the fuck the kid wants.
I don't know what it is about me about it,
but it just gives me so much joy when
the kid doesn't get what he wants,
you know? And when the fucking
kid gets what he wants. I just,
I always think you fucking pussy.
I always think that, I don't know,
it has to do with my childhood has
nothing to do with children or, or, or,
or my beliefs in a what we're
trying to do with acis or item.
Just being honest with you
fuckers. Sorry, I'm after.
I'm punishing these people with my French.
I'm trying to get my American,
my American back together. We speak
American over here. This is America.
We speak English.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
sought guns and roses for the
first time in my life Monday night.
And uh,
got ridiculously hooked up.
Yeah.
But I'm not going to name any
names and be a douchey here,
but I just want to thank everybody who
fucking was a part of hooking me up.
And it was insane.
We basically sat on the side of the stage.
They gave us these inner ear monitor.
So we heard the band mix and you could
hear axle making jokes in between songs
and stuff. You know, if he saw
something, just making a random comment,
it was fucking amazing.
It was amazing.
It was like being in Bill Bella checks
headset and I have to tell you something.
That fucking show might've been
the best concert I've ever been to
and
I don't even know where to begin.
First of all,
we're in a fucking giant
field right outside of Paris.
The Sun was going down,
there was all these beautiful clouds.
And my view is basically
I see the backs of, uh,
of all the musicians s which
with the son fucking going down,
I got some killer. I mean granted his
cell phone pics and everything. But like,
first of all,
they didn't tune down any song.
They played every song in the exact same
key that axle sang them in 30 fucking
years ago. And he crushed it. I,
I can't overstate how well that
guy's voice, how well he song,
how great his, we sounded like the fucking
record. And they did a three hour show,
three hour show. I'm an old man.
Okay. Fucking hour and a half.
I'm, I'm usually ready to be done with
it. But this three fucking hours in,
I was actually sad when it was over.
MMM.
I, I don't even know where to
be. It was fucking unbelievable.
Slash took this amazing
solo axles. Uh, uh,
voice sounded incredible.
Duff sang a song and then they had,
they threw some covers in there too.
You know,
I don't want to ruin the show for
people who want to go see him,
but every covered they did,
mmm.
Was by some other B singer
that sang really up in the
higher register and a axle
crushed all of it.
And um,
it's the best the band is sound sounded
since way back in the day. I feel, uh,
back when that classic one that they
aired on MTV that I watched a thousand
fucking times, that one where they
were, I think they were at the Roxy.
Was that what it was in New York?
And um,
okay.
I remember that was on,
I had taped it on VH VHS tape on the fee.
And there was, who's that fucking
VJ with the long blonde hair?
And he used to wear the leather jacket.
He was from Europe or
something and he was going, uh,
this band supposed to be the next big
thing. If they live long enough. Right.
What's amazing is 30 years
later they're all alive. Uh,
but that was the big thing.
Um, but anyways, I, I,
it was fucking unbelievable.
That's all I'm going to say.
So if you get a chance to see them
on this tour, definitely go see them.
Like I said, I, I can't remember the
last time they sounded this good a,
this might be the best day ever
sounded so, and um, and that's it.
And Neil was going fucking nuts
during the show. She actually,
she actually got a reaction from duff
and slash and I'm sorry, and a axle,
duff big smile laugh and watching how
crazy Neil was going and then actual
actually imitated the dance that
Nia was doing. So needless to say,
she had a great fucking time and, uh,
I am smiling now thinking about it.
There was, it was the perfect
fucking way to end that trip.
Um, so there you go. Um,
and now I am back and I,
Oh pilly Oh, freckles is
jet lagged. I did my best.
I stayed up until eight o'clock.
MMM.
You know, last night. But then the old
Kiddo got up at three in the morning,
so I've been up since three and that's
been a mess. Um, I uh, oh by the way,
I finally broke into that fucking bottle
of that chocolate salted vodka lik core
and what it was something I don't
even, what the fuck it was. Holy Shit.
Was that a hangover?
I don't even have that much.
I was just drinking vodka was just
pouring it into kind of like, you know,
spruce it up and it tasted
like ass. But uh, you know,
it was given to me by a relative,
so it was like, I got it.
I got it out of respect for them.
I got to drink some of this shit.
And the next day I woke up and I was like,
oh my God.
It wasn't even a hangover. It was like
a body pain. And I felt like I was,
I was going to Puke. Like, I just
need to get something to eat.
So I go down, I go down
the hall, the hall,
I'd say sample.
Oh.
However the fuck they talk over there
and I'm looking for a bull jury that is
open. Yeah. And I find one night
I just got a couple of croissants,
a couple of pounds do
shock a lot now for me,
I was getting it for everybody
and uh, but I, I was,
I was fucked up until I got on the plane
and I basically had to start drinking
again. It was one of those sort
of hangovers and uh, oh my God,
I got so mad at my wife where they had
us with a 6:20 AM pickup and my wife
goes, man, that sounds kind of early. You
know, we not taken off til 10 20. Right.
And she pushed the pickup
back by 40 minutes, you know,
and I love how she doesn't live in Paris,
made this judge that same sounds early.
So for an extra 40 minutes asleep.
And,
um,
I'm one of those people if they tell
you to get there two hours before I get
there two hours before, you know,
not a care in the fucking world.
Cause I know I don't do well with
that kind of stress. All right,
you want to stick me in a
bar with a bunch of animals?
Fucking throwing shit at a stage.
I can handle that.
I don't know why cause I grew up with it.
A bunch of animals but like when it
comes to that type of shit. All right,
well you looking at,
you know you got your wife and your kid
and you're looking at a 10 hour flight.
If the fucking people who live
there and know where the airport is,
say it's a to to get picked up at
six 20 to get picked up at six 20.
Okay.
She pushed it til seven
and everything was going great till we
got there. Those Air France, grumpy,
grumpy fucking people working there.
We asked this lady was like no help.
Where the fuck do we stand in line?
Where do we check in?
They tell us this one line.
We stand in it and then we get all the
way to the front and this fucking asshole.
Okay.
Is they knew him is you, you got to do it
online. The WWE beard. You do. But, but,
but it's like fuck it.
Some of wearing the exact same shirt as
you told us this was the right line and
he was just like, it was one of
those guys who just takes joy. Okay.
Fucking ruining your day. So then
you, then you had to go over it.
You had to basically check yourself in,
put the tags on your bags,
weigh your bags through the whole thing.
I was a fucking,
I was working at the airport.
Yeah,
I'll tell you, I'm just, give me a
self, a tip at the end of it. Okay. Um,
it was ridiculous. And then
we finally get through, um,
you know, all know, and then
she had to go, you know, go,
go in exchange or whatever the fuck you
do there with getting your tax money
back.
She had to go fucking do that.
We stood in the wrong line and time's
ticking. Time's ticking. Time's ticking.
And we got picked up 40 minutes later,
then they said we should
have and next thing you know,
we finally get through fucking
security and I'm just going like,
this was so fucking stupid.
We get through security and we have to,
before we even go, not security, we get
through customs, we get through that.
Then we have to,
we've discovered at that point we
got to walk over half a terminal,
get on a fucking train before we get
into this shit show security line.
And uh, yeah, we were
going through the line.
They were already boarding the plane
and I, oh my God, was I fucking mad?
I was just like, it wasn't so,
it didn't have to be this way.
So my wife does what she always
does when she's wrong is,
and she knows she's wrong.
She just immediately apologizes,
you know?
So then now what am I supposed to do? So
now. Okay. Oh well she said she was sorry.
She said, you're right. I
messed up. I'm sorry. But yeah,
but now we're still in this situation.
I don't know.
My wife would do that in war,
you know,
if I was up on a fucking roof and she
gave away our position and then all of a
sudden we're taking on fire and she'd
just be like, you're right. I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have shuffled
my feet like that. What?
I said I was sorry. You know
what? They do that shit. What?
I thought it was, sorry, I didn't know.
You know what you just like being mad,
you know,
and that they just turn the whole
fucking thing around on you.
So I'm sitting there,
go on their board and the fucking plane
right now and all these fucking animals
are going to be taken our overhead
compartment space and I'm just
catastrophizing. I'm fucking, I'm
like that dude and platoon, look,
I got a bad feeling about this
man and she is acting like a,
what's his face and Kelly's
heroes. Um, uh, what's his,
it's a puts a beautiful bridge
baby. It's going to be there, right?
She's all fucking Donald Sutherland.
She's all fucking relaxed and
I'm flipping the fuck out.
And of course we get on the
plane, you know, we get there,
they're still boarding the plane.
We get on, everything's fine.
The overhead compartment above
our seats close and I'm like,
it's going to be fucking pack was shit.
And I opened up, it was completely empty.
Everything was great. And uh, you know,
then she tries to turn it around
like you see, he see, look,
the planes even leaving late, like
what's the problem? I said, oh,
that's a great idea.
So next time we go to another country
or we're not really familiar with it,
let's leave 40 minutes later and let's
just count on the fact that the plane's
going to be late. Know,
look, I thought it was,
sorry. I don't know what more you
want from me. What do you say to that?
It's like, I don't want
you apologizing now. Okay,
I got to get the anger out
first. Then you apologize. Okay.
What? I said it was sorry. And then it
all fucking goes away. Jesus Christ,
you know, God forbid I do something
fucking bring it up for nine years. Right.
What I said it was sorry. Yes, but
that doesn't, blah, blah, blah.
Anyways, so I'm back here in the states.
I been up since three in the morning.
I got caught up on some of my, um,
some of my shit that I had on the, uh,
I still call it the Dvr, whatever the fuck
he called them digital God damn thing.
Now I watched the, a moto
GP race from, uh, Spain.
I watched Jorge Lorenzo
absolutely dominate, um,
I guess he's won two races in a
row for Ducati, right. Davitt CEO,
so crashed out for the second
time in, uh, in two races,
three races I guess.
Um,
so I guess that's causing a
weird situation over there.
I don't know much about it,
but I can tell you that, uh,
I'm hoping since divisio seems like
he's rapidly going to be out of this,
that uh,
Lorenzo keeps winning racist because
I would love to see him and mark has
basically go neck and neck for
it the whole way, uh, to the end.
You know, I hate when like to guy
basically has it wrapped up in September.
You know, Valentino Rossi made his third
fucking podium in a row. It was great.
Cal Crutchfield finally got around that
cut, took him like fucking 20 laps,
but he did it. Um, I
enjoyed it. You know what?
I was very tempted to
try and go to that race,
but I just couldn't leave my daughter,
you know what I mean?
We had a relative over there helping us
out and, uh, it was going to leave them,
you know,
it just felt weird leaving a con country
that isn't my country and leaving my
daughter.
So I said fuck it.
And I was getting a little bit too
caught up in the am turning 50.
You only turn 50 once. Yeah. You only
turned 51 once or 49 once, asshole,
you're a dead. So I was like,
all right. You know, um,
I got hammered on the plane though. My
wife got, she was fucking pissed at me,
um, had a little bit, you know,
I was thinking I was already
going to be on the wagon,
but that's just sit that long ass flight.
And um,
I watched that. Oh, I watched
that fucking movie. Dunkirk nine.
All you guys saw it in Imax. I fucking
blew it. I was too busy and I missed it.
I watched it on a little airplane, um, TV,
but oh my God.
Was that movie unfucking believable and
I knew it was going to be unbelievable
because this is thing out here
in Hollywood where when people
cannot handle that somebody is that much
more talented than them. They act the,
they say the same thing.
I had a buddy of mine saw that movie goes,
did you see Dunkirk yet? And I was like,
no, I did. And I got to see it. It hurt.
It's unbelievable. He goes, yeah.
He goes, I left. The movie was like,
I don't even know what I just watched.
Like I don't even know what I just want.
I think what you mean, you've donated
that fucking so fucking war movie.
You asshole. Jesus Christ.
Brush up on the history channel.
World War II hit Liz,
driving the allied forces into the ocean,
made a huge fucking blender
because he made a left turn.
He couldn't resist Paris.
He went down to Paris to go down to get a
Boulogne jury to get, you know, a shock,
a lot to panic,
a little fucking frosting.
And His fucking Charlie Chaplin Mustache,
he fucked up.
What he should've done was annihilate
us on that goddamn beaches.
What the fuck he should have done?
It's one of the great military blunders.
Even I know that, I know that cause
Joe Barton, Dick taught me that, right?
Joe [inaudible] Nick is a, is a, uh, he
knows all about fucking World War II. Um,
and then I watched the movie and it was
just basically a about these people,
you know, in, in the, uh, was
it, what's it, the French army,
the English are mainly English army.
There was some French people there
to try and get the fuck out of there.
So they didn't die.
I mean it was pretty basic
what was going on there.
But the way it was shot was incredible.
And I've just noticed out here in
Hollywood was when somebody is like,
like when you see a fucking movie at
that God damn level, I mean I don't,
how would you even write that script?
It was just so much action going
on with no dialogue. And it was,
it was breathtaking moving. It was
incredible. And like, you know,
one of the great things about knowing
that you're a fucking moron as you can
enjoy somebody else's genius.
Yeah.
I was just sitting there, God, I could
never fucking do this. This is incredible.
And I loved it and his buddy of mine was
just going, yeah. I don't even know why.
It's just watched.
Okay.
Well,
I mean,
I can see if you fucking watched you and
one of those stat films and somebody do
shit on somebody. I don't what
the fuck I just saw, but I have,
I'm trying to forget it.
Um,
I remembered that when that Batman movie
came out with that actor who played the
joker and won the Oscar.
MMM.
I'm so bad with the names and like
his performance is the joker is,
is right up there with anything
I've ever seen any actor do.
And I remember seeing this other big
actor after he watched that movie saying
the exact same fucking thing. Like, I
don't even know what I just want. I mean,
maybe I'm not smart enough. I don't
know what that movie was supposed to me.
I mean,
okay.
I, and I didn't want to just walk
and maybe you don't, you just watch,
you just watch one of the great acting
performances of all time and it's making
you feel a little fucking
certain way about yourself.
Okay.
Give it up. You asshole. What's
the matter? Huh? What do you play?
The green lantern and all of a
sudden you fucking can, in a way,
this guy played the joker. Um, I don't
even know what he's just watched.
So anyways, so I watched that movie
and uh, I had a script to read.
I'm a Hollywood guy. Even in business
class, I'm reading scripts, right?
That's what I do. Okay. To See, Ooh, which
cop am I going to play in this movie?
So anyways, I, uh, I started,
you know, I went up to
the front, you know,
I was walking my daughter up down
the aisles and then I see this,
they got a bottle of Glenn
and I was just like, Oh shit,
there we go. All this stupid wine
and cheese in this fucking thing.
And I just poured myself a glass of wine.
And when I saw, when I saw that, why
couldn't have done that, I wouldn't have,
I couldn't have done that for my kid. I
know a lot of the flights at Blur, right?
So I brought my kid back and then
that's where I had the glass of wine.
And then I saw that Glen 11 and I
was like, oh, that's what I want now.
What the fuck do I do with this?
So I just sucked it down
and yeah.
Then I started drinking that stuff.
And the second I break out like
any sort of fucking brown stuff,
like Nia eyes are on me.
And,
uh, you know, I had the glass of wine,
I had some shitty American food and I
had like three of those Glen Levitz and I
got a fourth one. Right. It's a
10 hour flight. I was pacing it,
I was keeping myself, I was
doing the Keith Richards
thing. He did nice. You keep,
you get, you get nice, right? And
then you just kind of keep it there.
You don't get fucking messy or
whatever. But uh, I got the fourth one,
she gave me the eyeball,
so I just set it down right.
And then I fucking took a nap
for not more than 20 minutes.
And when I woke up it was gone
and I was looking at,
she fucking told that lady to take the
Goddamn thinks and I had to just sit
there,
you know,
beginning my initial descent and to
just sitting there stone fucking sober.
Yeah.
MMM.
I Dunno. So anyways, that
was my last little hurrah.
So now I'm on the wagon on the wagon,
you know, woke up this morning,
he had my steel cut oats,
my two eggs over easy banana
and some strawberries.
Then I'll probably have some Ezekiel
bread with some fucking almond butter.
And of course for lunch
I've already made my keen.
So I learned how that's how you
say it with some black beans,
maybe a little salsa. Then
I'll probably, I dunno,
later on the afternoon have some
exciting chick pea pasta that I'll have a
protein size of my hand with some sort
of garden salad and then I'm just going
to crush waters and a hit the elliptical
back to that grind.
My vacation is over. No more
questions. No more baguettes,
no more. Glen Levitt. All right.
Back to being regular.
I'm back to fucking Clark Kent.
Uh, it's actually good. You know
something. What's great about eating,
drinking like a pig over
there is you fucking,
you know,
by the way we, we, we, we have, you know,
I told you I had a relative
on the plane too. Okay.
So it wasn't just my wife's sitting there
is her husband got shit faced. Okay.
It was my wife and another relative
staring at me while I got shit faced.
I get shit faced. Right. But I got a,
you know, I was definitely tailgating.
How am I going to lay off?
I, I'm going on the wagon.
They got the bottle
sitting right up there.
I paid all this money for business class.
Um,
I always give her shit. I've given I, you
know, am I going to get into it? You know,
she gives me shit.
What the fuck are you going to do?
Okay.
You know what I should've
done? I should've worked.
What? I'm sorry. You fucking,
you can't be drinking all this.
You're going to,
you're going to pass out and you got to
pick anything. That'll be what I said.
I was sorry. What? I said I was sorry.
Um, all right, me undies,
everybody. Here we go. Oh Dude. Oh,
don't [inaudible] me undies drinking
on the fucking plane. Doo, Doo,
Doo Doo beyond these Maya,
Andy's, my wife is a fucking pain.
If I pass out,
she takes my drink.
I wake up and I make a stick and then
she doesn't talk to me for a couple of
movies. And then we land
at lax. Where in me undies.
Mandy's. You've definitely heard me talk
about me undies. Hey, who's kidding?
Who you've heard me sing about
me on these? You know the fun,
comfy undies that feel as good as they
look to those of you haven't tried them
yet. Listen Up. You can get an incredibly,
you can get incredible underwear
sent to your door with me undies,
meaning no more hunting around for the
perfect pair at a crowded store and
eventually setting for settling for
good enough monies are made with a
sustainably source material
from beechwood trees.
Still don't know how you make
underwear out of trees in there. Soft.
Okay.
Fucking Barney rubble shit.
They're naturally soft.
Fiber makes a fabric that
won't sag down or write up.
Okay? That's what it is. It's flying.
The underwear flies in formation
with the nuts. Trust me, once you,
you put on a pair,
you're going to get it.
Mondays is so sure you'll love the
first pair that if you're not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you
into the right pair and if they can't,
okay.
I just realized,
you know,
some people's balls hang one
hangs lower than the other.
Maybe that's what the problem is,
you know, get somebody on there.
Can you describe your, uh, your genitalia.
Okay.
Um, and if they can't keep
them and they'll refund you.
So it really is risk free to try
the best underwear ever. Okay.
Now are you looking in a
mirror and make sure your left,
you're saying your left
testicle hangs lower. All right.
Is there anybody there that can confirm
this can look at you just in case cause
we know but would just be packed.
People when they look in a mirror,
they get conf confused about which uh,
ball they're looking at.
All right? We're just trying to make
sure that this is, is a wind. Winfield.
And if you're already part
of the [inaudible] family,
tell your friends about it
through their referral program.
They'll get a discount and you get a store
credit. It's a win win. Still not sure.
Well Mandy says a deal for my listeners.
First time purchase,
yours get 50% off their first
pair of undies and free shipping.
That's 15% off plus free shipping and a
guarantee that you and your [inaudible]
will be happy together.
I can't see me have and
my balls or no one else.
Get your butt over to [inaudible] dot com
and treat yourself to get your 15% off
your first pair of free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You go to me undies, dotcom. Slash.
Bird that's [inaudible] dot com slash
burr oh look who's, oh look who's back.
I love these guys. I don't want,
here's a product that I love.
I use and I back butchers box.
Not to be confused with nature's box.
Mother Nature's butchers box.
Put your box delivers healthy,
100% grass fed and grass
finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage bread.
Pork heritage bread breed, B, r, e.
E. D. Heritage breed pork. Sorry,
directly to door and I'm gonna tell you
that is the best God damn porkchop I've
ever effing had. Okay. It's,
it's fucking delicious.
The incredible quality of butcher blocks
meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely before we
kill them and free of antibiotics and
hormones. Each box comes with at
least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual size meals.
You can choose from five different
box types. All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork. The mixed box. The custom
box with such, you choose your own cuts.
A Guy, I cannot tell you how many. Oh my
God, that pork chop, that piece of port.
Oh my God, it was fucking delicious. How
about butcher? How put your box works?
First we feed the animals
that we let them outside.
Then we shoot him in the head.
Choose from curated boxes including a mix
of high quality beef, chicken or pork,
or customize your own box.
Meat is frozen at the peak of
freshness in individual vacuum packed
biodegradable packaging. All meet is
delivered right to your doorstep for free.
This is 100% true.
This is exactly what was my experience.
Then you throw it in your freezer.
You thought what you want,
you take out your fucking skillet,
right? You sear it on both sides.
You finish it in the oven,
take it back out,
give it a little butter bath
with some fucking garlic. Oh,
is that a tasty portrait?
What's your box believes in a healthier
food system where everyone has access to
meet the way nature intended.
Uh, free of antibiotics.
He spelled meet rock. You spelt it m oh
no, you spelled it right. M. E. E. T. No,
it's mea. T meet is, I'm going
to meet you over there. Uh,
and hormones said humanely raised.
Can I please hosted the fucking
national spelling bee? Uh,
meat can use it in a sentence.
A, a fucking meet me over there.
Okay.
Um,
Cook with the peace of mind knowing,
feeding your family healthy.
Hi. Ah, just got cut off some.
So I'm going to cut off the healthy high.
Something other convenience.
Think of butcher box is your neighborhood
butcher with their quality beef,
chicken and pork delivered
right to your door.
Choose your delivery frequency
with customs and I's level.
Subscription recipes are
available on butcher box.
Website and videos are available
to follow. That's perfect.
So you get this great cut of meat.
You don't want to fuck it up.
They'll show you how to season it and
then pretty soon they'll have videos.
They're doing everything but coming
over and cook in this sink for you.
If you have received a butcher box,
part of the read includes your purse.
Include your personal experience.
Hey,
this is as personal as it gets for $20
off your first box and an order of free
bacon,
go to butcher box.com
repeat entire call to action.
Well,
why don't you write it again for $20 off
your first box in and an order of free
bacon.
Go to butcher box.com I think this
will be slash burr and enter in Promo.
I says unique URL and enter Promo code.
Who gives a fuck?
It's delicious.
Just go there in order to promote
a butcher box.com. All right.
He looks everybody.
There's nobody on the planet like you
and that may or may not be a compliment
depending on how you are. So why would
you buy a mattress built for everyone else
working with the world's leading
sleep experts? That's as a,
there's a great fucking job.
Go back to your high school reunion.
What ever happened to you?
I'm a sleep expert.
Helix sleep developed a
mattress that customized to you.
I can tell by your buns you're not.
You don't have the right mattress
that's cust. Okay. He looks healthy.
Sleep developed a mattress that customized
to your specific height, weight, sleep,
and sleep preferences so you can have
the best sleep of your life at an
unbeatable price. They must be
amazing, Huh? They have one that knows,
you know which way.
If you lean it on your side,
if you junk does or does not touch the
mattress so he can kind of, you know,
cradle it. Here's how
it works. Go to helix,
sleep.com fill out their
two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll design your custom mattress.
They can even customize each
side for you and your partner.
A very progressive
did not say spouse too.
They say partner, right? Although gay
people get married in most states, right?
Maybe you call your dog partner and what
you guys do behind closed doors is it's
your own damn business
in 2018 he looks sleep.
Could you please not bring up beastiality
during the read? Other than that.
We loved it in 2018 he looks
sleep has taken custom,
customized sleep to the next level.
What the hell?
It's pillow pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position of body type,
fully adjustable.
I'm just picturing somebody punching
it like you'd do it with anything else.
There's be something more to it than that.
Likes sleep has thousands
of five star reviews.
Plus you get a hundred nights to
try them out. Graphs, go to Healy,
sleep.com/bar right now and you get
up to $125 on your mattress order.
That's, he likes sleep.com/burr for
under $25 off your mattress. Order.
Helic sleep.com/ [inaudible] all right,
that wasn't bad for being jetlagged
jet leg. Billy, what's the deal?
Um, anyways. All right,
so I'm back on it back on it.
I did 50 minutes a yoga this morning
at like four in the morning because my,
uh,
my lower body is not feeling good
these days riding on all these goddamn
airplane. So I'm going to go get a
fucking massage today. Have somebody jam.
They're fucking elbow into my hammies.
Try to free him up again, you know?
But calves are all fucked up.
Um, I got to Smith Seuss, right.
Fucking kills me in a good
way, right? I swear to God,
like my calves when she was pushing down
on it, no one's ever like, I didn't know.
You know, back in the day, if anybody
ever gave me massage debate, anybody,
any part of your body's sensitive
like, yeah, my calves, my calves.
So they would stay away from,
I didn't realize that that meant
they were all glued up and shit.
So this person has been
working on it and I,
I'm literally coming up off the table at
barely any pressure from the elbow and
she goes to see what's, what does it feel
like? Like what, what type of paint I go,
it feels like there's a ball of Hornets
in my fucking calves.
Um,
but I've just been too
busy to have her finish it,
get it all back to the
way it used to be because,
because whatever cause in my fucking
life. But I have to tell you man, um,
being a 50 year old man now, if you,
if you could find a good misuse,
uh, the, the quality of life that
you're going to have, you know,
if you stretch,
if you eat right,
if you don't drink Glenn all the
way back from Paris, which I did,
I'm exaggerating for comedy
effect. All right. I'm
like, I was having this
problem where I would be,
I would lay down and I would watch TV
for like sometimes as little as like 20
minutes. And when I would go to
stand up, like I had to stretch.
That's like how fucked up my calves were.
And um,
like I felt like my Achilles
tendon was going to snap,
like something was going to snap.
So I've just been having this woman
beat the shit out of my legs and a Co,
this is,
you know why I found out it was back
when I had that sciatic nerve issue. Um,
and I felt a little twinge of
that starting to come back,
just that little bit of
tightness. So, uh, I dunno,
she can to turn me into hamburger tomorrow
hopefully. Um, and that's it. All right.
That's the podcast here for this week.
So great to be back here.
Thanks again to everybody and a Dublin,
Ireland,
Ireland that came out to the show thanks
to everybody, London, England, uh,
you know, thanks to everybody in Paris,
France for putting up with my French.
Um,
thank you to guns and roses for putting
on the best concert I've ever seen.
And uh, that's it. I guess
I'm just really good. Thanks.
Enjoy the music.
And you can listen to another half hour
of a Thursday afternoon just before
Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Greatest hits from the Thursday early in
this year or years ago. I have no idea.
All right. That's it.
Have a great weekend.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then we started watching this
series on Netflix.
It was something about these chefs.
It was all these, these French cooks.
And uh,
it was great to hear the French language
cause I kinda stopped once again,
it was picking up, you know,
little phrases here or there
that made me feel good.
And these fucking,
these chefs were incredible.
We watched like two or three
episodes of it. Of course,
I don't know what the name of it is,
but it made me want to live in Paris for
like fucking three months, four months,
five,
whatever it would take just to get kind
of passable and take a pastry making
class. I know that sounds
like the stupidest thing ever,
but this fucking guy,
he takes like an apple and he was
going like this guy was an artist.
He was just sitting there going like,
you know,
I was so of making all these fucking
thing. Hey, I had to come up with some new
thing to do with an apple.
And he fucking just imagine if he
just kept peeling a thing. Right.
If you would just peeling the skin off,
but you just kept going all
the way down to the core.
He did that and it was all one piece you
did with some hand crank thing and he
said,
I wanted to make a rose out of out of an
apple and he somehow did it and turn it
into a dessert.
Oh, fair visual. All the hose. No.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
city sauce to Lima.
Fucking chop did duck in a, in a chicken
in half of he sewed them together,
which was very naziesque slash American
horror story that kind of creeped me
out.
Sse Cohen.
They were
afraid of access. Security on
perceive smiles, I'm presuming.
And then of course they had to show how
they fucking, they were cooking lobsters.
Live lobsters over an open flame. Can
I can show you guys a question. What,
what are the lobster ever do to us?
Yeah.
Every other animal has the decency of
being dead before we fucking least in this
country.
I know other countries,
they got fucking maggots running around
their apple jacks for extra protein.
You know, that's like us putting
way potter into our shakes.
They put like fucking bugs and stuff,
you know what I mean?
Puts a little spring in your step. A
little twinkle in your eyes. So anyways,
I'm watching this fucking lunatic and um,
for the life of me, I don't know why they
just can't. At least just can you just,
yeah.
Fucking,
I dunno.
Can they make it like a little
lobster hammer and just fucking knock,
knock it out.
At least does it have to be squirming on
the flame and you have to keep telling
me that it doesn't feel pain.
It doesn't have a central nervous system.
Whatever the fuck they try to say.
It's just like,
okay,
like what? It's like an
Amoeba. It isn't. Okay.
The fucking things got eyeballs and shit.
It's walking around.
It's got its little tentacles.
What'd we call it? Those,
those big fucking thing's coming out.
It can see it breathes.
You got to have paid. That's
part of survival, right?
Which shows a way to shut it off.
MMM.
Jesus. I'm all over the map. I
was talking about La fucking nut.
She always talking about Alabama, USC,
now where the hell am I? So anyways,
the guy got sick of talking about a big,
after a while he just got sick
of the blood of all the animals,
excuse yourself, of a sig.
[inaudible] city Tammany
eight.
I push her button.
Do you have your own fee charging?
And he got three stars over in and um,
in France in three stars
is the highest you can get,
which is so fucking Parisian.
You know what I mean?
This is so fucking understated and classy.
I hate to say it as America,
but they really are. They really earned
their snooty fucking behavior over there.
The people that style that closed it,
did they crush it? You know, Mr t,
we got himself a gold chain and
there was this like, you know what,
one isn't enough. Let me get fucking
9,000 of them and hang around.
They're the exact opposite of that.
They got like all more
muted colors and then Bam,
a sick ass pair of shoes or a hat
or the ladies with their bags,
just fucking class. It's not like, you
know, it's not like as loud Americans,
you know?
Huh.
But it's good to be loud sometimes.
Hey, what's going on? It's Belper
and it is the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, June 21st, 2010.
How the hell are you? God Damn
it. You like that? That's my like,
come on, let's fucking do this. You know,
like he gave up on your dreams and you
picked an easy fucking drone route.
Got a job at a corporation and
I'm the first guy that, you know,
you're going to meet and I'm trying to
get everybody on all, on the same team.
Come on everybody.
You know,
let's go look at some spreadsheets.
Okay?
Why can't I fucking hear myself?
I'm screaming right now and I'm not
hearing the volume in my headphones.
He's had phones getting old. Okay.
You don't, are they made in America?
Is anything made in America anymore?
I have no fucking idea. But anyway,
so I'm actually taping this
on, um, what is it? Sunday,
June 20th. So it is father's day.
So happy belated father's day,
everybody, you know, I hate that word.
Belated happy birthday. Happy Birthday.
Happy Father's Day to all the
fathers out there who stuck around,
you know, happy father's Day. You know,
even in the father's, you know, you're
married some Twat, you realize you didn't,
you didn't love her anymore and you know,
she fucking took off and started banging
the fucking dude down the street.
So you flipped out,
he threw some furniture and now you're
considered a danger to her and your
children. You can't really see him
today. Happy Father's Day to you too.
But no happy father's day to somebody
who just knock somebody up and never hung
around.
You're not a father.
You're a guy with the Dick who shot a
load into a vagina and you fucking left.
You left, you're riding the
bench. You're not in the game.
So a
happy father's Day fuckers.
Um,
what'd you get?
You get some shit gifts like all guys get,
you know what a women, what do women get
on mother's Day and what did they get?
How they get fucking pancakes.
You know,
what does a guy get a new breathable
shirt for when he goes out and Mo's the
lawn that day? Is that
what you get? Some fucking,
what do you get a new driver?
I'm a dad.
Get some fucking tool for the garage.
Something to help you fix the
fucking place up. You know,
I got a lot of balls actually got my girl
a gift certificate to gift certificate
to some cooking classes, uh,
one year for her birthday,
you know, and that was one of those gifts.
As I gave it to her, I was like, this is,
she's either going to love this or I'm
really going to piss her off because it
is a very nice gift. But
there's also an element of, uh,
why don't you learn how to Cook
Bitch. Um, but it wasn't that,
you know, this is actually
a Gore Mace, you know,
whatever I'm going to
fucking make out in the deal.
So douchey gift and I gave it to,
I've looked her right in the eye and
said he'd go, here's my gift to you.
That will make my life better because
you'll become more of the person that I
want you to be. Does
that make sense? Anyways,
I had an awesome weekend working down the,
uh,
the Improv in Hollywood sold out three
shows. And let me tell you something.
It's a small club,
but it's still,
I was very impressed that everybody came
up because that's a hard ticket to sell
here in Hollywood.
You know,
when Leonardo Dicaprio's also having
a pool party the same fucking night,
do you think anybody wants to come
down to the Melrose Improv? They don't.
When the fucking corona girls are showing
their twats up on Fairfax and Sunday
sunset, Sunday sunset or whatever, that
all that Hollywood shit's going on.
So the fact that everybody came
down to see me was really awesome.
And even though the Improv spelt
my name incorrectly on the Marquee,
B U R R r Bill Burr,
we'll be performing tonight. Uh, I had
a great time working out my new hour,
some hiccups here or there and,
uh,
all the shows went great except for
the late show Saturday night. Uh,
it was kind of had a weird show
where there was this woman talking.
This lady was rubbing it,
running her fucking mouth as they
do, you know, they can't help it.
They're emotional.
Do you know women say like twice
as many words a day of men.
What you fucking Dick?
I didn't notice.
Do you think none of us didn't notice?
You know,
just cause you're saying twice as many
words during the course of the day
doesn't mean you're really
saying anything. You know,
ever been hanging out with people and
everybody's running their mouths about how
to solve a fucking problem and there's
that quiet person in the corner and like
when three words,
they sum up what the fuck we should be
doing this because you're running your
Yap doesn't mean you say anything.
Just cause all you broads out there
are so fucking afraid of silence,
you know,
because your clock is ticking or whatever
the hell's going on with your fucking
bodies.
Jesus Christ.
The of fucking cycles.
Sorry, I don't know why I'm
being so ignorant right now.
I respect women, you know,
and their wounds and their ability
though to uh, you know, take a load,
you know,
and then fucking walk around as it gets
created with no effort on their part
whatsoever.
You know,
me shooting the load really doesn't
take any fucking effort, you know,
a couple of strokes back and forth.
I'm a good two minute man.
Does that feel good? Ah, that's
it. That's my game. Deal with it.
You got to focus.
This is really disgusting.
I usually don't do sex jokes like that.
A lot of bodily fluids so far.
But once again, I'm doing, I'm
doing this, uh, this part. Oh
No, no, no. Stay on target.
Stay on fucking stay on. Stay focused
here. I was going to talk about that. Um,
the, uh, the third show. So
I'm doing my show and you know,
it's going great and I hear this
yammering and the, you know,
out of my left ear and I
look over and Lo and behold,
it's some woman talking to this
other woman. And I said, hey, hey.
And she was so involved
in a conversation that I,
she couldn't even hear me,
you know,
standing 10 feet away with a
spotlight and a microphone.
She couldn't hear me say loan.
Hey ma'am man.
Yes you ma'am, please. Huh? When
you listen to me, thank you.
So she shuts up. I do my shit
and then like five minutes later,
I don't know what she did. She
started heckling me. And by the way,
when the crowd gives me shit that's
heckling when I give them shit,
I'm not heckling. There's like four
people came up to me this weekend.
I liked how you heckled
that woman in the audience.
Heckerling is what an
audience member does.
We'll have the definition up on the EMM
podcast.com where you can get all your
little tidbits,
you little fucking bacon bits off of
the podcast if you new to the podcast,
eat.
If I,
if I throw out references that you don't
understand and when I recommend youtube
videos and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
do I have to go to youtube and I
have to look up all these videos?
Wouldn't it be great if there was a web
page that just had all the videos that
he recommended and pictures
of the references that he
made in links to shit that
he talked to.
Rather than me having to make a list
on posted after posted in my fucking
cubicle.
Well,
we got that for
you@wwwdotthemmpodcast.com you go there,
you'll see all of this shit
and I described that so
well I totally forgot what
the fuck I was talking
about. Oh, that's right.
A definition of a heckling tackling is
what somebody in the crowd does to a
performer. All right? There's
all different kinds of heckles.
There's you.
You could be heckling even saying
something nice fucking up my rhythm.
I was walking down the street the other
day. Oh, I've done that. I love streets.
You know, that's a form of heckled. It's
one of the hardest hecklers to deal with.
All right, but when I'm trashing someone
in the crowd, I'm just doing crowd work,
doing crowd work. If they didn't say
anything, hey, where are you from?
That's playing with the crowd.
But it is not heckling.
So stop coming up to me at
the end of my show is going,
I like the way you heckled that guy in
the crowd. How exactly did I do that?
Did I sit in the audience and then
put the audience on fucking stage.
All right bill. We got it. You made your
point. Okay. You're right. You're right.
Sorry. So anyways, um,
anyway, she like after I said,
ma'am, ma'am, ma'am, hello,
I'm trying to do my act here.
I got back into my act like five,
six, five or six seconds later, um,
she yelled something at me, something,
some sort of non sequitur. Oh, I said,
I got to take my dog to the dog
whisperer. And she goes, should I go?
What? She goes, you said dog.
Whisperers so I went, Shit.
And it was just dead
silence. I was like, what?
And I was literally looking at her
like, does this, does this person,
is this person mentally
challenged before I go?
Because you've got to make that assessment
because you don't want to do that,
you know? So, uh, I dunno, you know,
what ended up happening was she had a
major issue with the fact that I called
her ma'am, you know, which brings up,
you know,
a very interesting point in your life is
where a woman goes from young lady to a
ma'am. And when a guy goes
from young man to a sir,
you guys all remember the first time
somebody called you sir or Ma'am and you
were like, Jesus Christ, I'm fucking old.
But after a while you deal with
it and you start, you forget.
You forget that people
are even saying that.
Especially cause most of the time
nowadays when someone's calling you sir or
ma'am, it's some Douche on the phone
that you're trying to get to help you,
but they can't help you. Yes. And
sorry sir, I understand sir. Yes.
Well there's nothing I can do. Therre
ma'am, ma'am, I'm trying to help you,
but I'm sorry, I don't know why
they transferred you to me ma'am.
And you're just more pissed off about
the subject. But there is that moment,
the first time somebody calls
you sir, man, which I get,
but if you saw this lady,
she was at least fucking
eight years into being a man,
you know. In fact, a good friend
of mine watching the show,
Neil Brennan was standing back at the
back of the room and after the show he
goes, she was so a ma'am,
you know, and she was,
she looked like that girl who played
Nelly on little house in the prairie.
Remember that? The 13 year
old cunt with a fucking, uh,
Cindy Brady haircut it 15
and she was just a cunt,
the entire fucking series.
We'll just imagine if that client
was now fucking like, I mean,
this girl was like 36,
37 easy eg. You know,
she already had,
you know,
when you start getting the
[inaudible] is that whatever that the,
it's not your chin, they call it
a double chin, but it's really,
it's the flesh between Your
Chin and your Adam's apple.
It starts to sag a little bit.
Gravity has been pulling on it.
She had that and about two tons
of fucking blush on her face.
And um, oh, she was such a, you
know, she's Douche bag of the week.
She was really douche bag of the week.
She just kept running her mouth.
And um,
I know I got to think why I try.
This is hilarious after everything I just
said this week on the podcast so far,
I try not to attack this few
things. I don't do, I don't,
I don't make fun of mentally
challenged people. You know,
I did that a couple of times in my career,
did not go well and I felt
like an asshole afterwards.
So I cut that out and uh,
you know,
I don't go after women's looks.
That's usually,
that's usually a last resort because a,
I don't know, it just, it just,
you know, this, believe it or not,
this certain things that are to me,
but on the podcast,
evidently I can fucking go off on
women. Is that what it is, Bill?
I'm trying to think of all the
shit I said in the last 12 minutes.
I'm sure I'm being totally fucking
hypocritical right now. But whatever.
It's my podcast.
I'll speaking of that shit.
My girl was watching one of these dumb
ass fucking shows this week. You know,
those shows the, uh, the real fucking
horny housewives a fucking Toledo,
you know,
and they got their faces fucking Yank
back and they're desperately trying not to
be their age for whatever fucking reason,
for whatever reason. You know, why
can't they have them looking like moms,
you know,
so he can actually relax and enjoy the
show and look at someone who's 42 who
looks 42 and they're happy and they're
in some sort of a stable relationship.
Rather than showing these cuts,
going to these fucking art
shows and sipping wine,
is it doing squats up against a fucking
refrigerator desperately trying to hold
on to their youth. It's fucking over
lady. You got like three kids relax.
I'm not saying become disgustingly out
of shape, so you have heart disease,
but to sit there and go to the mall
and at your age and by the latest,
the same fucking genes
that the kids are wearing,
you look ridiculous.
You look for Dick this whole fucking,
uh, what is it? Cougars, is
that what they call them?
You know, it's sad. The same way.
It's sad when you see a fucking older guy
doing the same shit hitting on fucking
younger girls. It's sad. But of course
when women do it, it's empowering.
Anything they do, it's fucking empowering
the exact same shit. We do all this,
you know,
we're sad.
We're sitting at Hooters and we're
fucking pathetic and everybody goes off
saying, I'll, you know, fucking sad.
Our lifestyle to a woman does it.
They can make a goddamn series of it.
Why can't you know that Cougar town,
when they make dirty old man town
and they do it in the
fucking guy would be,
would be considered a fucking
creep and a woman does it for us.
I guess it's considered an accomplishment
because guys are so visually motivated.
They're like, wow, an old bag. Like
you can still get a young guy. Good,
good for you.
Good for you.
You with your lizard tits and see,
there you go. Being hypocritical again.
Sorry. So, uh, anyway, she's
Douche bag of the weekend.
I actually use one of the few times I
ever have somebody kicked out, you know,
the bouncer came over the first, I
was like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm kind of enjoying this. I like a
little bit of back and forth and um,
I thought we were going to get
to some sort of resolution,
but like by the fifth time I went back
and forth with her, the whole crowd,
they weren't laughing. They just went, Oh
God, shut up. So then that becomes like,
okay,
now people aren't getting their money's
worth and that's gonna Affect my fucking,
you know, career. So you got
to go. So they kicked her out,
they kicked her out and I'm sure she drove
home feeling like it was some sort of
victory thi that he kicked me out
because he couldn't deal with me. Hey,
that's her playing with their chins.
Um, it's like, no, if you just,
you just sort of a content,
everyone wanted you to
leave. You know what I'm say,
cut too much more in this podcast.
I've noticed that and all of a sudden
I've made up for it in the last three
minutes I made up for
the last 26 podcasts.
Um, so anyways, what else? Oh
Jesus. Let's delve into it.
The Boston Celtics loss to the
Los Angeles Lakers in seven games.
Man, it was fucking brutal. Uh,
one of the ugliest seven
game sevens I've ever seen.
And um,
if you really look at the series in
general, it was a pretty ugly scene,
the whole fucking series.
And uh,
I don't remember last week when I was
like, you know, we're in a good spot,
but I can't, I can't get any read on
this series because it was so fucked.
So the only pattern I could
see was the Celtics were old.
So when they flew out for game one,
they were tired and they got
the shit kicked out of them.
They get a good night's sleep.
They went game two. All right.
They fly back to Boston, they're
tired again. They lose the game,
get a good night's sleep to come back.
They went games four and five fly
out to la. They're tired again.
They get their fucking asses kicked,
they get a good night's sleep.
I'm thinking they're going
to win game seven. And uh,
they did not, unfortunately. I just
think, you know, Kendrick Perkins,
that was just too much for us to lose,
took on too much water and uh,
the Lakers were just younger,
more talented and um,
you know, when they get 13 of
the first 15 fucking rebounds,
I don't know how we were still
winning that game, but um,
you know,
it was definitely brutal.
It was fucking brutal and as much
respective I had for Pau Gasol,
I started the fucking hate him again.
You know the fucking asshole man.
It's like he,
before he even drives to the hoop,
he already has a look on his face.
Like he's getting fouled in
the way fucking flops around.
I was joking around this weekend,
you have a drive by some shitty carwash
and they have like that sell restock
fucking looking thing. It looks like a
guy and they, and they shoot air up into,
and it's fucking arms flap all around.
That's what Pau Gasol looks like
going to the fucking hoop. And I'm,
and I got to tell you something,
you know,
I'm not taking anything away from the
Lakers because I just think out of all
four major sports,
the officiating in the NBA is
absolutely fucking horrific.
To the point I've been
saying this forever,
that the refs literally dictate
the pace of the game. You know,
it used to be the point guards when they
wanted to speed it up and slow it down
or whatever, guys on either team would
do things. The point guards, they would,
they'd pick it up or slow it down. Now
it's the refs. Now it's the Reps. Oh,
let's let them play first half.
We fucking tackle cobia one play.
They let it go. I'm like, that's exactly
how you should be calling this game.
It's game seven,
let them go.
And then when it really fucking
counted in the fourth quarter,
they were just running down the
court with their whistles in there.
Miles and I don't want to be country here,
but what the fuck?
You know what I mean?
None of the Lakers were fallen people
and then all that bullshit with the
relationship. I mean, I get it.
Kobi drives into Rashid kobies
the face of the league. I get it.
He's going to get the call the same way
Tom Brady gets the calls the same way
Jordan gets the calls. I
get that and I, you know,
but if Rasheed Wallace is
standing sideways with his
arms down by his side and
he's not moving it
fucking jumps into them.
I get the no call because it's
Colby and he gets to superstar rule.
But if you're gonna call a foul that's
fucking offensive to put Coby on the line
on a horse shit call like that during
game seven. Man. That's the fucking refs.
And I'm not shitting on the lake
cause I'm not taking this away from,
but I fucking hate the NBA reps
get out of the Goddamn way.
Let them play.
So fucking annoying.
Go all the way to game seven and
it's decided on penalty shots.
It's like that fucking World
Cup soccer such as, you know,
I've, I've gone back to saying
it's a stupid fucking sport.
Can somebody explain to me
the offsides and soccer,
why you're not allowed to
get behind the defender.
That defeats the fucking purpose
of every sport. I understand.
Like,
you know,
one guy just can't run down the field and
be hanging down by the other guys net.
I get that.
But the way the dif,
the defense is the offside line that
basically moves down the field and you'll
see an offensive players start to run by
it and the defensive player just stops
running.
So then what the offensive player has to
stop running because of defensive guys
out of fucking position. It's, it's no
wonder you have one to nothing games
Neal. Neal, what a contest.
Jesus Christ and those fucking
idiots down there blowing those,
those horns that sounded like mosquitoes
for the whole fucking game. I haven't,
I'm going to get involved in the second
real reason why I haven't gotten into it
was because I was watching,
um, I was watching the Lakers,
Celtics and uh, you know, whatever.
Congratulations. Lakers fans, you know,
whatever. God bless you. I'm
past the hate. I don't do
that shit. But, uh, you know,
and that was a hell of a celebration
too, that you guys had. You know,
that was awesome. You win a championship.
Yeah. Let's go tip over a car.
Take that you fucking automobile
talking shit. The whole series.
Now what do you got to say?
Huh? Storefront window.
I didn't think so.
That was what really surprised me is
the classless level of fans out here.
I don't get it. It's so
bizarre. We have the, uh,
the court side Laker fans,
which is the highest douchebag factor,
even more so than the Boston fans.
The few who dress up like leprechauns
that make me want to hang myself. Um,
the douchebag factor. Everybody
went there. Ashton Kutcher,
bing Crosby hats on
and their rockstar jewelry.
Did you see that one game? I think it was
game seven when they won and they won.
They were cutting to, uh, the three
guys announcing the game. Van Gundy,
Mark Jackson and a fucking whatever
the other guy's name was ed. Uh,
that fucking like 48 year old
guy holding his gold jewelry.
I think he had like a Laker pendant.
You know,
like he's 21.
The whole fucking thing was ridiculous,
but I don't get how you
have like around the court,
you've got these fucking fans.
They show up like halfway through the
second quarter that are on their cell
phones and shit. Text messaging.
Like, did you see Courtney cuts?
Cox sitting us speaking of Cougar town
sitting courtside she looked like she was
waiting to get a fucking nails done.
No emotion just sitting
there in her leather pants.
So it really looks like there's not a
lot of passion or at least on the side
court behind under the hoop you
can start to get real Laker fans.
But then like up top, like,
I don't understand those
people. Those people take it.
I think they're making up for the,
uh,
who gives a fuck attitude of like
the cast of whatever new hits.
Sit-Com got the fucking court side
seats and they start tipping over shit.
I Dunno. It's like, what
are you Canadian fans?
I gotta be honest with you for
as much shit as they give Philly.
Philadelphia fans, you know
they, they throw, they throw a,
they threw snowballs at Santa Claus.
Oh yeah.
Did they tip over a police
car and light it on fire?
Did you see that shit after they won?
That's what kills me.
They won and it looked like
fucking Tiananmen Square.
The only time I ever saw that in Boston
was after we broke an 86 year curse and
you knew some shit was going to go down.
You knew it that much fucking rage.
But they want it two years ago.
You see that? I'm justifying
when we act like Douche bags,
but when we win a basketball championship,
we don't freak out.
I don't know. I gotta be honest with
you. Sports out here, it's, it's not fun.
Like back east,
there's a lot of shit talk and there's
a lot of ball breaking and believe me,
I took a ton of Shit in New York,
but there was an element of fun
with the misery. But out here it's,
it's not fun. You go to games out here,
you know, you go to a game in Philly like,
okay, someone's going to dump a beer
on me, me, bell get puked on, you know,
you come out here, you like, you know,
I think I'm going to get stabbed.
And I had that experience at a fucking
charger game at an angel's game and uh,
actually not at a Lakers game, just at
a charge was Lakers and a Dodgers game.
And um, you know, I dunno,
I mean granted, the,
the common denominator in all three of
those is the fact that I went to a game,
but whatever, I talked, shit, I
get a little drunk, I talk shit,
Talk Shit back to me,
you know,
that's now what we're supposed
to be doing. But you know,
to take it to the level that
you're going to fucking stab me.
I don't fucking know. Ah, right. Let's
get on. And then I'd like an asshole.
I sat there and I watched the,
the post game,
the Lakers post game where they had a
Michael Cooper when some chick from the
WWE NBA,
you know,
you would think with all the Great Lakers
that they could another fucking Laker.
Great if they wanted a former player.
But I get it that trying
to hype the fucking w NBA.
So this fucking twat comes on there,
right?
And starts the WNB.
A chicken starts trashing Kevin Garnett,
which is such the classic cunty thing
to do where it's like, first of all,
sweetheart,
you are on the edge of your seat and
didn't know the Lakers were going to win
this series until there was about 41
seconds left and now that you won,
you're going to act like it was in
the bag and she's, she was trashed.
And Kevin Garnett, right?
Kicking him when he's down,
the guy comes off major knee surgery,
his fucking arm was jacked up.
He never bitched, never made
any excuses, never responded.
When Pau Gasol said he's lost a step,
never said shit and this shit goes,
the big ticket should have called
them the big coupon. You know,
if Katie, what a fucking
classic. It's just unbelievable.
Say out of a fellow athlete, you're going
to do that. I could see, you know, even,
uh,
a former NBA player maybe,
but a WNB a play. I was joking
about that shit all this weekend.
The W NBA really? You're going
to talk shit about Kevin Garnett.
Fuck it. Yeah. What do you get your w NBA.
You got to have a fucking bake sale at
halftime. See a check doesn't bounce.
I Dunno.
It was really,
I was really surprised that the classless
level of behavior with the fucking
people trashing the downtown,
her talking Shit,
and even Michael Cooper still being
like a cunt where it's like you won,
you don't have to think is it's
really easy to be classy when you win.
And they couldn't even do that.
So I kind of lost an element
of respect for the Lakers,
but I'm sure they don't give
a fuck. But, uh, um, I dunno.
But I'm actually proud of the Celtics
because if you looked at it on paper,
we should have got absolutely destroyed
and somehow it went seven games.
And I don't know. I don't know how the
fuck we ended up losing it in the end.
We actually, we know what the Lakers made
a great adjustment. MMM. What's his face?
Ron Artest when he started
shutting down Paul Pierce. Yes.
And no one else could step it up.
I thought that they made
a great adjustment and uh,
we couldn't overcome it and then they
went on like that fucking 13 zero run.
And uh, that was it. And what really kills
me as a Celtic fan is that Coby shit,
the bed shit,
the bed,
like we're talking about a John
Starks level in a game seven. Okay.
And once again,
I was going to feel vindicated the
same way I did with Peyton manning when
everyone was saying you're arguably
looking at the greatest quarterback of all
time. Same thing with
Colby Bryan. All right.
It's fucking guys who keep trying to say,
compare him to Michael Jordan. He's not.
Okay. Who's the second guy to
go to the moon? Does anybody?
Exactly.
Cause no one gives a fuck.
Did a second guy go to the moon?
Did we ever go to the moon? That
was a bad example. You know,
who's the second guy who made a
light bulb work? Nobody knows.
Just be you doing something that's already
fucking been done by somebody great
does not make you on
the same level of great.
It's when you do something great
that's never been done before.
That's what separates you. Okay? I'm not
going to go into this fucking rant again,
but Coby Bryant shit, the fucking
bed and that fucking Mark Jackson,
Jesus Christ, he's got a
poster, a Coby over his bed.
At one point,
Coby was too for 19 and game seven two
for 19 it's somebody a fucking van Gundy
brings it up when you had
fucking Jackson's like, yeah,
but he's got 12 big rebounds,
but guy, he runs down the court.
I love the shape of his calves.
He shit the bed,
Pau Gasol kind of shit.
The bed to miss missing
all those foul shots,
that bearded ballerina with his
fucking fundamental European game.
You don't miss those, but it
was game seven. He bitched
up a little bit, you know,
but you need a little bit of luck to
win it. And I think a Rashid going down,
same with the Celtics. We got lucky in
2008 when uh, when buying them was up,
you need a little bit of luck and
the Lakers had it. God Damn it.
And they want another one. And you know,
there are up to fucking 16 championships.
The franchises and Laker fans can stand
hand in hand with another man from
Minnesota and say we together have 16
or as in Boston we can stand like men on
our own and said, we got 17 all
right, fuckers, you fucking cunts.
Oh God, I'm so pissed. Jesus Christ.
This was really Russia to watch baseball.
I Dunno.
Why tapped off from baseball or watch
the Bruins lose four games in a row.
Have to be an up three games to none.
And then I watched us lose a seven game
fucking heartbreaker to the Goddamn
Lakers. I was so hoping we were going
to drink champagne. Jesus Christ.
What were you fucking Laker fans do?
If you lost,
burned down the staple center,
you have to go back to the fucking forum.
That would actually be better.
I like to form better.
If you guys ever been to the form, he
got to go out there. It's legendary,
legendary. You come in there, you can,
you just can see the old showtime Lakers.
You know, you can see all the whores
lining up waiting to fuck magic.
He used to get head right on the bench.
It's back when the NBA was great.
They'd let you play and the
fucking players would get
blown right on the bench.
There was no w NBA,
those bitches were on their knees blowing
the star players and the NBA check it
out. It's all up on youtube if
you don't believe me. So, uh,
so I got a couple of predictions.
I have, um, the same way, uh,
how the steroid case,
um,
started off small and became,
I think that the NBA has a major
problem with their fucking officiating.
All right. And once again,
I'm not making excuses.
I gave it up to the lake because you
were younger and you're more talented,
you deserved it. You clamp
down on defense. Okay, we
good? Can I make this point?
There's something going on. I don't
know what, I'm not on the inside,
but remember I said that
there is something going on
with those officials there
either.
You know,
they had that one guy who got busted
for having mob ties and somebody claims
somebody at the Improv last
night was trying to tell me,
and I obviously I can't back
this up like most of my shit,
but they were trying to claim that some
gamblers have been calling this guy in
prison,
call a phoning this guy and they'd been
asking for gambling tips and he's pretty
much dead on.
If you tell him who's playing
in what the officiating crew is,
he can't pick against the spread,
but he can tell you who the
fuck is going to win. Um,
just because he knows the personal
vendettas they have and you know,
and if you look at Rashid
has been a dick for years.
The refs fucking hate him.
That's why when he standing flat footed
sideways and Colby jumps into them,
it's an offense. It's
a defensive foul. So,
and I get it.
It's hard to set your personal shit aside,
but it was game seven. You fucking
Asshole, you know. But anyway,
I don't know. I think, uh,
I think it's a little fixed,
but it can't be fixed because
the Lakers didn't even cover,
I don't know what's going on,
but there's something weird going on.
This at the very least is
some new officiating style.
I think the reps might be finally just
fed up with the fact that they only make
150 grand to fucking run up
and down a basketball court,
which to Uri is a great job,
but I think they're sick of getting
cursed out by 22 year old tattooed
millionaires. I think they're tired
of it. And they've decided that, um,
I dunno what they decided something,
but I don't know, you know, something.
I don't watch NBA hoop enough nowadays to,
to,
to really be 100% about debt.
But any,
any hoop fans out there?
Can you, can you go with me?
That doesn't seem like there's
something weird going on. It's,
it's the, the, it's like
even when you watch baseball,
if somebody has a fucked up strike zone,
it's a consistent strikes
on for the most part. Okay.
He sees he's calling that low on a
strike tonight and for nine innings.
That's what the fucking guy does.
And as much as it pisses
you off your first at bat,
now you kind of know the guy's parameters.
But like with the officiating,
it's like they,
they letting it go,
then they're calling everything and
it starting to make me feel like,
because it is a business that if one
team goes, goes up by too many points,
the officials kind of do shit to make
sure that stays close so they get that
advertising money.
I Dunno.
Am I just pissed because my team lost.
I was saying that shit before when I
went to that game when Garnette blew his
knee out and fucking a Utah that it
seemed like something weird was going on.
Who knows?
We'll see what I think next week when I
maybe started to get over this fucking
loss. You know, it's the worst is when
you, when your team shits the bed,
like the Bruins stayed.
Or if your team
loses a seven game heartbreaker
to your absolute arch rival.
The hardest thing is like, you can't watch
TV. You can't watch any sports TV camp.
I've been watching like the food network.
I was actually watching a
show the other day on a,
on this HD channel that has all this
shit with like a bunch of cars and stuff
like psycho into cars. My Ocd. Um,
I've gotten totally into cars and uh,
so I keep going to this channel and they
actually had this unbelievable show.
It was basically about the bird and magics
of like marine corps and army snipers
throughout the history
of the u s military.
They had the Michael Jordans of
snipers and they had this dude,
man, it was fucking, it was the
most fascinating God damn show
I've seen in a long time.
And I,
and I stumbled on it because I didn't
want to watch the sports center, you know,
the sports and watch sports center
and listen to bill. You know,
Celtics didn't get a dog,
you know,
you know those things to do and there
you didn't do it. It ain't good.
I can't fucking watch that shit.
I know. I got it. They lost.
Um,
and I also didn't want to watch Colby
jump up in the score table and do his one,
two, three, four, five, five rings.
But he really should be doing is counting
how many fucking points he had that
weren't from the foul line.
Sorry, had to get one more in. Um,
so they showed this dude like, uh, I
remember, uh, that big battle in Fallujah,
I guess it was in 2004 if
he could fucking believe it.
It was already like six years ago.
And there was this marine corps sniper
who had like 32 kills in 30 days and they
were talking about this guy was like
shooting through like a softball size hole
at targets that were like four or
500 yards away. And it's something,
again, accuracy up to 600 yards, six
fucking football fields. All right.
And you're peeking out from behind
the rubble. I think it's okay.
And then Blab,
you're fucking the backyard.
It gets blown out.
And they were talking about what a
psychological mind fuck that was.
And then there are also,
they try to find you but they can't peek
their heads out because this guy was so
fucking bad ass.
Like Rick Barry from the foul line.
He's picking these dudes off and then he
picked the dude's off who would try to
drag the dead dude out of the street
just like in saving private Ryan but
reverse cause it was an
American guy doing it and uh,
Eh, it was, it was absolutely
fascinating. Then they went to,
after they were talking about that guy,
he has to sit there and those guys,
what they do on the other side is
they just start lobbing like, uh,
was that mortar, those, you know, they
stick it in that tube and goes, you know,
it shoots over a couple
of condos and he goes,
you just got to sit there and hope one
doesn't have your name on it. You know,
why do I watch action movies where there's
actors who pretend to be bad ass when
you can watch shit like that.
It was,
it was one of the fucking manliest
things I've ever seen in my life.
This guy was just picking people off.
He has to take into
consideration cross winds,
how quickly these guys are running.
He was going after the guys like the,
it's like a video game. Like the RPG
guys were like worth like 2000 points,
you know,
if you just got some guy running across
the street trying to get a fucking to
bully salad, that was
worth like 25. Anyways.
So then after they got done talking to,
talking about that guy,
they talked about that they
cut to this dude and um,
in Vietnam who had like
93 confirmed kills and uh,
he went head to head with
some other bad ass sniper. Ah,
who's on the Vietcong and the
Vietcong guy spotted them.
This is how bad ass the Vietcong guy was.
He shot around by his foot as a challenge.
You know, this guy was bored
with picking off regular people.
So he wanted to go mano a mano with
this other sniper and for like four days
they're tracking each other through
the, through the jungle, you know,
coming up on each other's flank,
whatever the fuck that means.
One dude would be like 300 yards in front
of the other dude and then they'd be
crawling on the fucking elbows is
somehow by the time they were done,
he'd be where that dude was.
And then the other dude was with the other
dude was and just one day the via con
guy got unlucky
and it was the afternoon sun in it.
It glinted off his fucking,
whatever the word is there.
This is his gun scope in this guy
literally did the shot from saving private
private Ryan.
He,
he shot it through the guys' scope and
blew out the back of his fucking head and
the guy had a southern accent talking
about, went through the scope,
didn't even touch the sides.
It was great. He was like, he
was talking about some fishy cut,
a Yay shit buddy. I was down. I
caught a fucking fish on dry land,
mother fucker top that one bitch.
He was doing that.
But talking about killing
guys, I don't know. I have,
I wish I knew the name of the show,
but I found it absolutely fascinating.
What are those shows that
so manly that you get,
you almost get insecure watching that you
have to somehow start fantasizing that
you're the guy in it,
you know,
and you start talking shit like you're
the guy getting interviewed and you're
whisper and to yourself on the couch
and then you catch yourself going,
Jesus Christ. Am I fucking
crazy? You know, for the record,
I was getting interviewed on Oprah
and then you wonder why I'm
in this business. All right,
it is hot as hell in here. I've got
to keep the windows close. You know,
when you say cunt, every fucking three
seconds, I get to keep the windows closed.
Um, all right, let's, uh, let's get to
some of the shit here on the podcast. Oh,
I wanted to,
I forgot to mention that I was going to,
I was on Joe Rogan's podcast.
Um, had a great time.
I went out to uh,
his bungalow and I did as podcast two
and a half hour podcast that went by in
like three seconds. Um,
and for the life of me,
I don't know where the hell
did he tell you to go get it?
Just look up Joe Rogan podcast.
He's like hardcore into the Internet
and technology and I'm sure his website
will take you by the hand and
lead you right to his podcast.
So please check that out.
And uh,
one of the things we talked about on our
Rogan's podcast was he was absolutely
beside himself that I was
not on Twitter yet. Um,
oh first that I didn't have a what does
that thing you have in your car when you
don't want to look at a map anymore?
Keeps saying Gee, cast g map.
I map map 2.0 fucking do it for me.
I don't want to think
anymore. Um, mapquest,
fuck, what is it called? Whatever.
I don't have that thing. I
just had, I have a map. Can
you tell me where you live?
And I look it up and then I, I I
get there. There is no problem,
but for some reason people
are blown away by that.
But it was even more blown away with by
the fact that I, I wasn't on Twitter,
so he actually signed me up for a Twitter
account and I told him I don't do that
shit. And he goes, uh, he kept saying,
you gotta do what you gotta do it.
It's the best way to hype you gigs.
So I'm asking you guys,
should I get on Twitter because I don't
want to go into that on there and tweet
about some fucking cheeseburger. I just
had, um, I get like most people do,
but a Rogan was swearing up and down. This
is, this is the best way to do it. Like,
he's like,
you don't even need to do radio.
You just get a bunch of followers on
Twitter and you tell them where you're
going to be and then they
can all go out and see you.
Like that fucking Korean barbecue truck
that drives around here out in La.
People are on Twitter to see his fucking
truck that has insane Korean barbecue.
And people are like, you know, follow the
thing on Twitter and they're like, Hey,
I'm on so such and such and vine and
everybody drives over to go get some
fucking Korean barbecue. So, um, anyways,
we have a poll on the Mlm, podcast.com.
If you guys, you know, if you'd like it,
if you want me to be on Twitter,
uh, I'll do it. I'll do it.
But I gotta be honest with you. I'm not
going to be, uh, I'll only be tweeting,
you know, I'll tweet like I just put
the podcast is, uh, just got posted.
I can't even, I can't do Twitter
tweet. That's fucking ridiculous.
You know what it is? This part of me
though, I got to stop fighting this shit.
You know, by the time I got onto
Facebook, it was fucking irrelevant.
Nobody gives a shit. Now
everybody's on Twitter, you know,
I'm giving it a little bit.
I'm compromising. Fuck it.
What do you want me to do?
Huh? You want me to be the
spokesperson for BP? I'll do it
shit.
And you know something,
I could do a better fucking job
than their spokespersons are doing.
What's their latest spokesperson?
What? What the fuck is that guy saying?
They're only birds.
I got to open the window here.
Sorry, Cleo. Sorry. She gets so
fucking freaked out whenever I do that.
Then she starts shaking
uncontrollably. Sorry. All right,
let's get back to the podcast,
so let me know what it's,
it's Twitter is stupid as I think
it is or is it actually decent,
but I'm going to be honest with you.
If you say, do you get on Twitter?
I'm not going to be tweeting.
Just got an ice cream and the host
scoop fell in my laugh. Omg, lol.
I'm not fucking doing that. All right,
I'll, I'll have the most boring tweets,
but then that's the thing you
get on there. Then you got to,
you got to try to be fucking
interesting. Oh, gives a fuck. Go.
Go on the [inaudible] podcast.
Let me know what you think you know,
and maybe send me some emails and let
me know some of the positive things.
Even think, if you really think it's
sucks, just let me know. All right,
so there you go. All right, 45 minutes in.
Let's get to some of the questions here.
Um, if somebody send me, here's
another tech question for you. Uh,
somebody sent me something about a saying,
hey bill, I don't have an iPhone. Can,
uh,
you know,
can you make it easier for me
to listen to the thing at work?
I don't want to have to be, you
know, I guess I don't know what,
listen to it on the computer. So I,
I emailed the guy back like, well,
can't you listen to it on your iPod?
They seem like he had one of those jobs
where he, I forget what his job was,
but it was like he went to job sites.
Um,
I dunno,
is there another place where I can post
the Monday morning podcasts for people
to listen to it on their phones? I
mean, I don't know. I have no idea. But,
uh, he seemed to be the only guy
who said some shit like that,
but just in case it was a problem.
Uh,
if you guys have like tech
savvy fucking questions,
I don't know what to do about it,
but if you can point me in a direction
that will make it easier for you to
listen to this thing, I'll try to do it
as long as it doesn't involve, you know,
900 bucks in like three
weeks worth of work here. Um,
all right.
And also I added a couple of Boston
dates I got to put up on my website.
One is up in New Hampshire for
the life of me. It's Sunday,
so I don't know where the fuck it is.
I got to talk to my agent tomorrow,
but the other one is on August
12th, I'm going to be, and um,
the 2010 Newport summer comedy series
at the New Newport yachting center.
Huh? You like that moving
up in the world? Um,
yeah. Um, it's a seven 30 show August
12th that by the time you listen to this,
I'll at least have that,
post that up on my website and I
know the day before or the day after,
I'm going to be up in New Hampshire. So
all you people up in Maine, you know,
you people over in Connecticut,
you know there's a couple of gigs that
are easier to drive to. Hang on a second.
All right, here we go. Um,
youtube videos for the week.
Um,
here's one that I think is really funny,
but also I can't tell if it's fake or not.
Please let me know.
It's called BMW chase and it's a couple
of rednecks judging to people in this
little BMW car.
They chase after him and for some
reason they're filming it and um,
you think the guy in the BMW is going to
get his ass kicked and all of a sudden
the tables turn. It's uh,
it's pretty interesting,
but I don't know if it's real or not.
Um,
and also the 21 foot rule over that
last week, the guy put up one more,
he did a final video where he
actually hurts himself. Evidently
this guy is out of his mind.
And if I worked for the FBI,
I would definitely be watching
this guy at all fucking times.
21 foot rule, final video, go to the MM
podcast.com. All right. Just go there.
We'll have all of these up here.
And if you're a dog lover,
please do not watch this one.
All right,
dear versus dog. Um, it's a long story.
There's a baby deer and then the mother
dear comes in or it looks like an
adolescent tier to make
sure the baby deers okay.
And there's a cat that gets a
knocked around a little bit,
but the dog gets absolutely pummeled.
The dog gets pummeled
and it's,
it was really uncomfortable to watch.
But uh,
for some reason I'm telling
it to you and I'm laughing.
I don't know why cause it wasn't funny.
So if you add enough,
if you don't like watching a dog,
get pummeled by a deer, check it out.
But for you, future serial killers who
have already begun torturing animals,
there's a video for you. All right.
Underrated. Overrated for the week.
Um, this is a great one. Underrated.
Letting your frozen pizza cool for the
recommended two minutes after pulling it
out of the oven.
Good Lord.
That's such a classic drunk food or
like you're just absolutely starving and
you've just fired it in the microwave
or the oven and the second it's done,
you just fucking,
you'd do a couple of,
and then you bite into it and then
you got to do that. You gotta like,
you know like fanning your
mouth as if that's ever worked.
And then for the next four days, because
you didn't, you didn't wait two minutes.
You have that white burned flesh.
The top of your mouth have
somehow dislocated my jaw,
the fuck is going on here.
Went to the dentist and they gave me a
fucking mouth guard because I grind my
teeth at night cause I'm a psycho.
Oh,
fucking Corolla.
Evidently I do that at night.
So I got this mouth guard and now all
of a sudden my job pops in and out.
And you fucking dentists out there.
I gave you a big shout out last week,
but I'll let you know that I know both
canines a six and 11 eight nine or
downtown. Right. Okay.
MMM. Yeah. If you know how to fucking
do that every once in a while pops out.
Anyway, sorry. Plowing ahead here.
A overrated, those membership cars.
This guy obviously is a new listener, so
I think I'm up to 15 listeners here. Uh,
overrated. Listen to this.
This is unsolicited by me.
This guy's obviously a new listener
because sir, if you're listening to this,
I've done numerous podcasts about these
things and I also have a bit about it
coming in my upcoming special,
okay. Coming out in September, uh,
overrate he said those
membership cards with all the,
that all the fucking chain stores in
[inaudible] now trying to push on you.
Apparently if I give them my name,
email address and a record
of my shopping habit habits,
I could be saving hundreds
of dollars a year. Really?
I'm supposed to believe a giant soulless
corporation wants to help me out. Sure.
I may save a buck or two,
but when I buy a seat when I buy a CD,
but at what cost? At what fucking
cost. Exactly, sir. Congratulations.
You're a thinking human being. These
other people are just like, oh,
they're trying to help you out.
They want you to save money
while they make less money,
despite the fact that you would go
to the store anyways. They're morons.
And here's a recommended video. A movie.
Actually, I didn't check this out,
but this sounds like a great psycho movie.
I talked a little bit here.
I talked about snipers. I th I made
a reference to a serial killer.
So I think this is a fine way to end
the podcast here by wrecking them
recommending a movie called rampage.
At least find out more about it.
I guess it's a small independent film,
but it says a dejected by the futility
of is tedious life of bitters,
small town resident takes matters
into his own hands by constructing a
bulletproof outfit,
uh,
picking up his semiautomatic weapons
and attempting the largest killing spree
killing spree ever seen,
written and directed by a
controversial filmmaker who we ball,
I don't know you. W. E. B. O. L.
L is that EU ball ball.
This ultra violent action
movie feature features jarring,
handheld camera work and original
dialogue largely improvised by the cast.
How you watch that movie
is beyond me. I would love to hear
that. Improvised Dialogue, doot doot.
Oh, don't shoot. I mean,
what else would you fuck it?
Say acting like it's
fucking, uh, Larry, uh,
what's his face? Uh, Larry David,
I'm so bad with the fucking names.
Uh, anyway, sets the podcast this
week. It's a little short this week.
I got to admit I'm a little fucking
burned out. I did a podcast,
I did my podcast,
Adam Carolla's podcast and I did,
um, Joe Rogan's podcast. I did,
I'm literally making an unpaid career
out of these podcasts,
but they're there.
They're just a fucking there tie for that.
Say I did Adam Carolla's podcast to,
um, check his out. Is tis
actually, he actually,
he's one of those guys who actually
has 2 million fucking listeners and
advertisers.
His podcast is everything that I want
this thing to beat at some point,
but I'm just too fucking lazy
to go out there. You know what,
I would love to have a bunch of of
of advertisement on this podcast,
but it's of Shit that I enjoy.
You know,
like my respect for snipers.
Like if somebody wanted to
advertise their sniper scope,
are you sick of your neighbor?
Do you want to scare the shit out of
them or maybe take out a house pet check
out the fucking x m 3000
millimeter fucking gun.
Scalp,
even a fucking mute.
Good kill someone a 300 fucking
yards through a picket fucking fats.
Some shit like that.
Maybe we'll have that.
Maybe we'll try out advertising on this.
Do free advertising for random shit.
You know shit that I actually fucking
use like toilets now you shit,
you sick as shit and outside. Why
don't you get a toilet? You dumb. Fuck,
it's 2010 I like how everybody,
if there are more on,
has to have a southern accent.
I've addressed that in my act.
What else would I went out with it
kind of advertising Belvedere, vodka,
limes. If you make limes,
you grow limes, I should say.
What else? That's about it. Vodka,
guns, scopes and toilets. Let's
start there. That'll be the, uh,
the advertising, you know, their
minds be a long time ago. Um,
when guns and roses there,
their appetite for destruction came out.
They had that song called night
train and the people of a,
I guess it's some sort of cheap booze,
I don't know if it's wine.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
Um,
but the people at night train one slash
to be a spokesperson and do this is back
in the day where if you were
a spokesperson for something,
like you lost like 30% of your audience,
you were considered a sellout.
Nowadays, these fucking Lady
Gaga guys can be fucking,
have their legs spread around some Yo
play yogurt, make an extra fucking money.
Nobody gives a shit. But back in
the day, that was a big thing,
but he actually would have got away with
it because it would have been so funny
because their whole thing was
that we're were alcoholics. Um,
but at the last second, uh,
some groups complained. Yeah.
Um, that it would actually,
what would that do to the youth?
What would that encourage them to do?
And that's one of the Times,
few times that they were actually
100% right. Because if, if slash
okay.
In 1988 89 told me to drink
night train, I would have, okay.
I would have would have been hilarious.
We would've drank night terrain while we
listened to night train and out and our
safe suburbs. We would have thought
we were bad ass on some level.
Okay.
All right. I think that's it. That was
a little, a little fucking reminiscing.
I took you back to 1988 you know when
the first George Bush was in office,
you know when he had some
sort of restraint sorta
stick and move in the Middle
East. Just fucking blast him
right in the face and then leaf,
let them think about it. Don't let
them fly around the country. Um,
anyways, let me hide my guest for
this week. I am beyond excited.
I'm going to be in Las Vegas this weekend.
Co headlining with a
comedian and television star,
Tom Papa,
the host and star of the marriage.
Ref on NBC. Please watch
the show. Tom Papa,
good friend of my podcast,
and I'll be advertising.
I'm advertising Tom Papa right now and
we co headlining with him at the Orleans
Casino in Las Vegas a Friday
and Saturday night this weekend.
Uh, what the fuck dates of
those? Hang on. Hang on.
Don't get your panties in and up. Raw. Uh,
that would be the 25th
and the 26th of June.
Come on out. All you people in Vegas,
but asked me to come out there.
I finally got a finally got a gig
out there and, and as a comedian,
it's an honor to perform there.
That's the last place I guess
George Carlin did stand up. So, uh,
I'm going to try to talk to a security
and see if maybe I can not take a peek at
the theater.
Maybe make a quick little video.
I always promise videos and then
I never ended up doing them.
But maybe I can make a quick little
video of me working in Vegas. Uh,
actually cool Vegas,
Vegas video when I'm not out there
acting like strip clubs are fun
rather than their,
if they're fucking,
that's overrated.
Titty bars.
Titty bars are overrated unless
you're under the age of 23.
Okay.
You fucking, you know, 23 are under
strict. Did a titty bars are great.
Well you get a little bit older than that.
It's fucking horrific.
You just wasted money and it
makes you fucking hate women.
MMM.
And I think actually the strippers,
they start to hate guys after a while,
but I think that they would like guys a
lot more if they were fucking wide eyed.
2021, 22 year olds. Oh boy.
Oh boy. Look at the vagina.
I gave her a dollar and she showed
me her titties. Oh boy. Oh boy.
This is a greatest night ever
when you're still in that phase.
And I'm not making fun of 22, 23 years
old, old. Cause I wasn't that, that, uh,
you know,
I was that guy at that age and I'm sure
a bunch of you will email me now and
telling me how fucking bad ass Sherra and
all the pussy you're getting. You know,
I don't give a fuck. Okay.
I was your age actually.
It was I getting any at that age. I had
a badge. I was a late fucking bloomer.
You know, you don't, you know, the
middle period where mark McGwire uh,
right before he started doing steroids,
when he fucking tapered off.
That was like my pussy getting
career in my early twenties.
And then I moved to New York and
uh, it all worked itself out. Yeah.
If you can't get laid and moved to
New York, by the way, it's, it's just,
it's fucking impossible not to get this.
They're just walking down the street.
I was back there last weekend.
I forgot about that.
Like when you're driving
around La, they're in cars.
He can't get to them.
They're boxed in.
But in New York you can just
harass the shit out of him.
And it's like the host cities.
Just a big construction site.
It is sweet tits. Oh, come on.
You're going to be like that.
It's a matter. I just made you
uncomfortable. I just threw out a,
maybe you're going to get raped,
vibe. I can't believe you.
You're fucking giving me this
attitude now. I was never that guy,
but I actually,
I used to always meet girls in the gym
and oddly enough I actually met a couple
on the subway.
I think because they have their
guard up not to get mugged,
but they don't think that you're
going to start hitting on him.
And what I would usually do,
I think I told this story,
I would wait for somebody to do
something weird or fucking stupid,
which happens all the time on the subway.
And if they would react to
it by laughing a little bit,
then you went in and I had to do was
make a joke and then I was in, you know,
and hopefully if they had,
you know, if I got, you know,
I try to just get their number,
but if I got desperate,
I would whore out the fact that I was a
comedian. Yeah. Actually I'm a comedian.
I'll be down the comedy cellar tonight,
which is such a bitch move.
But I did it all the time.
Shamelessly had a business card with
me fucking holding a microphone.
So they knew I was a comedian.
You know,
the fuck I did what I had to do. Look
at me. I looked like Richie Cunningham.
What do you want from me? I look and
I'm over an hour again. Just like that.
That's how it goes. All right, so that
is, oh, a new episode of uninformed.
My taped with, uh, Joe to Rosa,
the new young teen sensation
of the opiate Anthony show. Oh,
I want to thank those guys,
by the way,
last week having me go on and height my
show, and I want to thank the guys, Kevin,
and being out here in La and Adam Carolla
for let me hide my shows out here in
Los Angeles. All the show sold
out and, uh, makes you feel good.
So that's it. Hope you guys have
a great week and let me know.
You want me to do the
tweak thing on Twitter? Um,
I know I'm really copping out here.
I'm acting like Julius Caesar.
Do you want me to kill this sonic
God, I mean, it's up to you.
I'll do whatever you want me to dope.
Uh, but God, the, uh, the FM podcast.com,
check out all the videos
and all that type of stuff.
Do you have a good week? I'm going to
start watching the world cup. All right.
That's it.